just to give you an example on why
Michael Jordan was interesting because
I've never felt well there's two people
well there's three mics that I've been
around that I'm like that's can I get
some cool
three mics three mics Michael Jordan
Michael Jackson
[Music]
Michael Buble
I don't think it's how you say how do
you say Buble Buble I say bubbly yeah
yeah this is like is that a real guy
though yeah nobody he's Michael he's got
to be a mic okay Mike um Mike Tyson yes
oh
Bobby for 300. so real quick so what
what I realized about them was like that
was the level of Fame that I was kind of
like oh my God like that's so crazy like
like when you go to dinner with Michael
Jordan or he invites you to go smoke
cigars like there's so much prep and
gotta make sure this is sealed off and
this is roped off and people and this
thank God this was the error when they
weren't um they weren't phones that were
recording yeah but people were like
staring and like they would come close
to the rope and Michael my
I love you Michael
great game they want to get his
attention while eating and ugh insane
and I was like Mike how you do this [__]
he was like dog just uh do it man I just
make sure I'm back here yeah I have a
good time I'm gonna tell you how famous
Michael Jordan was
well we already know no but I'm gonna
show you something just no no no no this
was so crazy and I thought it was some
[__] but it was really true yeah
they had a fake Michael Jordan sometimes
to make people Walk This Way oh decoy
decoys decoys whoa I do that sometimes
they need to decodes for me we have Dr
Ken Jeong
why I'm here decoy yeah yeah probably go
this way so wait wasn't your body double
like a chubby lady yeah you lying yeah I
did a um break dancing movie with Jamie
Kennedy called Kicking It Old School and
um in Canada they couldn't find a guy
with my body because they found a
Filipino dancer because I had a dance in
them I couldn't dance that well so they
got me a body double so yeah they got a
fat Filipino girl I love it yeah they
had a white guy they had a they had a
white guy be my stand-in in Canada
because there's no brothers up there
it was so [__] funny
I was just seeing them like this dude
I'm like
they was like he's your standing it's
really tough up here it's really tough
bill it's really tough I don't fight
Mike Tyson that intimidating because
he's so nice where where not nothing
back in the day maybe not like doing
back in the day yeah I'm talking in
there like not Mike now is like yeah you
can have my bike back then was like I'm
gonna [__] you till you love me ran into
me
anytime I swear I'm going I'm going to
hurt you I'm trying I'm trying not to
hurt everybody
like when you're Mike in the 90s Mike
was so famous like yeah he was in the
news every other night wrong something
outlandish like punching a guy in the
face leaving the Rolls Royce in the
middle of the street uh uh uh uh you
know or doing some charitable thing in
up in Brooklyn you're fighting yeah yeah
right here like so back then
and I'm coming up famous like I'm I'm
not even I don't want to say I was
famous yet I'm popular like there's
popularity you were famous shut the [__]
up you're famous man but that's it's
still another level so then I was like
damn you can't go to the movies no more
you got to have all these security
guards you got to have all these people
grabbing on you pulling on you and in
certain cases in my career where I I
felt that energy it was really crazy
like I'll give you an example
when I was on MTV we did Woodstock
and I was and it was live I think it was
94. look it up CO2 and you were and you
were there and I was there was it and it
rained oh I remember yeah it was a
disaster disaster and so I was
live with the people
and they were swarming me I had to have
like seven security dudes just so we
could shoot because they were like
[Applause]
yeah oh my God and they're all high and
they're crazy
and then it started raining so now we
all turned to Mud whoa I'm I'm doing
this yeah because I got to read the uh
yeah yeah and we're live and they're
changing we're Bill Bill we're coming
from Guns and Roses wait wait no no no
no Guns and Roses No Guns and Roses oh
you're going to you're going to Blind
Melon hey but that that was Blind Melon
wow see what I'm saying yeah so we were
live at the truck and [__] but when did
it start getting it was dangerous it was
getting dangerous when it started
raining and then it it started to a lot
of white people white people
yeah yeah especially if blind melons
playing because he that's like that's
what the song
I did Joe Cocker like look up look up
the the lineup the lineup was crazy but
this wasn't the Woodstock that like the
documentary we watched right well this
was it yes it was two it was one in it
was one the one I was at was um it was
in Saugus right yeah this was the the
tamer of the um yeah which ones were the
crowd was violent that was later on no I
was at the 94 I think it was 94 94. you
got Green Day holy [__] look at that
lineup
and then I know Joe Cocker performed
yeah I know um no don't go down to no
notable day one that those are like okay
there we go so I saw Joe Cocker Blind
Melon Cypress Hill Nine Inch Nails
Metallica listen
Aerosmith oh my God bro this is like
white boy Heaven yeah and and it was
such a spiritual thing what do you mean
because I think it rained on the very
first one too
so it was just like Jesus came with
something and so I will never forget
they all started lighting candles like
holding candles up at night it looks so
beautiful and it was just like mud and
people people were on ass anyways wow
that's crazy I never been around so many
people that looked like they didn't know
I was there
no I didn't but you could tell they were
like Bellamy yeah yeah wow it was like
they were looking at me like I was
inside a a bubble or something and I was
like what the [__] kind of trucks is
that wow yeah and that was a scary kind
of situation were you in a relationship
then uh no I don't think so you could
have I I had a good opinion yeah I was
very good at that wouldn't be very good
at what BD no no no no I was good at
like having a lot of um friends yeah
yeah oh my God it was nice times I'm so
jealous yeah no no no no no social media
no like um